I'm proud to welcome such an
accomplishment to show the great power
of courageous leadership dr. Bernard
Franklin
good evening thank you for welcoming me
here I'm honored thank you Michael Thank
You Heather thank you dr. Cohen thank
you to the faculty and staff of this
great institution and to the community
of Pittsburgh I am honored as a no name
to be here a no-name because you could
have selected any of the well-known
authors historians actors sports people
or even TV personalities but I see
myself as a local commitment worker in
Kansas City and throughout the country
helping people to achieve their goals
and their dreams I'm better known in my
community and a pair of jeans and a
sweatshirt but I'm here tonight to say
to you we can make a difference if we
want to we can make a difference if we
care we can make a difference if we move
forward and just begin a little bit I'm
here tonight also because I'm friends
with the King family and I'll take a
moment to explain that to you because I
want you to understand in a short way
that I'm going to share some bits of
history some bits of information about
dr. King that you may or may not know my
family picked cotton in Oklahoma my
parents were sharecroppers they were
very poor people who decided their
children would not be poor they moved to
Wichita Kansas to work for Boing but my
dad never did get on at Boeing my dad
ended up working for the US Post Office
for 33 years sorting mail the same job
he began with I'm the oldest of seven I
really had two choices go to school or
stay home and go to the streets now I'm
sure you're sitting back saying what
streets in Kansas City
well friends we have a small relatively
small community of poor people but
understand those poor people all around
the country i decided i would go to
Kansas State University it was a great
challenge to be one of the first African
Americans during this period when Kansas
State an agricultural school a grand
land institution was recruiting students
of color I have five roommates that
first semester but they survived and I
survived but you know what I went on to
say that I didn't care what they did to
me I was going to make a difference I
was going to get ahead because I'd gone
through this list as we described a few
minutes ago a list of affirmations I
knew who I was and I was not what they
were trying to make of me I knew where I
came from and I knew where I was going
now I was not much of a party guy
although I did do the bump and I want a
few dance contest contest teaching my
friends how to do the double bump I wore
kicking afro and on many times I had my
pick in my hair but I was serious
serious about going somewhere and
serious about making a difference I
graduated and went to work for AT&T in
Kansas City now my younger brother
defies my dad my younger brother says
I'm not staying in the state of Kansas I
want another experience dad wanted us
all to stay in Kansas because it was
cheaper on his budget cheaper because
in-state tuition was a little less than
out-of-state tuition but this aggressive
young man said I'm going to defy my
father so he decided to go to Morehouse
College dad said go ahead but I'm not
paying for it and I'm not driving you
there so little brother calls big
brother who's working at AT&T at the
time and says dad won't take me will you
drive with me too
atlanta so we get an hour Nova and drive
from Kansas to Atlanta Georgia little
green Nova we get to Morehouse check in
at the residence hall walk up to the
door and there's my brother's name
Gregory Ronald Franklin we were proud to
see the name but stunned to see the name
below it Martin Luther King the third
now we're standing outside the door you
got a picture this we're standing
outside the door saying yeah cotton
picker sons are going to have dr. King
son as a roommate we're just common
people common bread and butter people
from the Midwest so we're thinking
someone's changed the name we're going
to get inside there's going to be
someone else inside the door we're sure
enough we walk in and there's Martin
Martin is wonderful Martin says just
call me Marty so we call him Marty we
exchanged a few familiarities have some
conversation Marty says Bernard where
you staying and I said Marty I'm staying
at the omni Marty says oh no no no don't
stay there check out of your hotel and I
want you to stay with my mom and my
little sister Bernice no friends it
doesn't take a poor young man long to
realize he's had an invitation of a
lifetime I went back to the omni hotel
checked out of the hotel took my bags to
sunset Avenue knocked on the door and
miss King comes to the door now she's
gracious she's wonderful her hair looks
like she just stepped out of the beauty
shop she already knows my name cuz Marty
called and said Bernards on his way she
greets me she invites me in she shows me
my bedroom wonderful friends it is a
week that defines Bernard Franklin's
because here i have an opportunity to
talk to a woman to go deep into a
woman's life about a man i have had
great admiration for for many many years
so i go to the bedroom check my stuff we
end up having a conversation Oh like
many of you you're wondering what good
can come from Kansas we talked about
what good could come from Kansas she
talked about a Dodge City wanted to know
if there's any tumbleweeds that roll
down the streets she even asked me if
there was a place for Dorothy and a land
called oz we had some great conversation
but i think it was day two day three
America bombed Libya the first time we
went after a man remember called Qaddafi
kings queens presidents leaders of
foreign countries were burst on the
phone trying to get mrs. King's
attention wanting to her to explain to
them or give some discussion about how
would dr. King respond to America's
aggression against a small country
conversation after conversation I
watched this gracious woman articulate
with great grace and great dignity how
she thinks her husband would respond
against violence against great use of
force against a small country and each
time she would in the phone with Martin
would be honored that you call to ask
about how our country and our world
deals with human relations without
violence in between those conversations
we would get personal we would talk
about things mrs. King asked me what did
I want to be what do you pursue
what do you want to do with your life
and friends I had never told anyone I'd
always tuck this away way deep down
because you got to understand a little
African American boy from Kansas
probably doesn't have much opportunity
to get to where I wanted to go so many
of my friends probably would look at me
and say yeah right well I told her mrs.
King I want the white house I want to be
the first african-american president of
the United States mrs. Keane tucked that
away I saw the look on her face and I
and give you a bit more as we continue
this conversation as we talked further I
wanted to know how a young man the age
of 26 could step into the most demanding
the most humiliating the most pressing
role step right into Montgomery Alabama
I wanted her to tell me what possessed
him what caused him to move from comfort
what caused him to say I have to do this
I must do this and understand I'm 24
years old when I'm having this
conversation so I'm realizing that I'm
just two years away from where he is and
he is stepping into Montgomery Alabama
where on any day any day men could come
pick him up men could shoot him in his
back men could take his very life what
causes a man 25 years of 26 years old to
walk into Montgomery Alabama to defend
women who want to sit at the front of
buses what causes a man to to give up
his life knowing that at some point it
may happen what causes a man I wanted to
know this and so in between the
conversation mrs. King would say Martin
knew his
god Martin knew who he was Martin knew
where he stood in relationship to God
and Martin knew from a very young age
and I'll go through some of that Martin
knew this was the coal on his life
mccall do you have what sense of purpose
do you have what fears keep you from
walking into your realities what do you
need to do to overcome the fear to walk
into Montgomery the challenge I bring
tonight the challenge I want to leave
behind because too many of us buck and
towel behind other people we cower
behind somebody else's dream we walk
behind somebody else's line but we're
too afraid to walk alone too afraid to
stand alone too afraid to be different
too afraid to say what we need to say
even in the midst of challenge I
challenge you Pittsburgh don't let this
be just another holiday celebration a
man bled and died so we all could be
here a man gave up his life one man one
man so we talked more we talked a lot
about the civil rights movement because
I wanted to understand you need to know
when I was a young man that's all we
watched on TV I knew Walter Cronkite
like he was a family member because we
watched news and on occasion we watched
Ed Sullivan especially when the supremes
or any of those good people were there
but my dad was a news junkie and so any
time we knew civil rights or King
is going to be on the news all family
front and center so he was my man so I
wanted to know about the movement and so
we were talking and then I'd look around
the room and I see this this sparsely
decorated house you know many of your
homes we have stuff everywhere we got
pillows we got devans we got chairs we
got stuff all over the walls but this
house didn't look like that it wasn't
cluttered there wasn't a lot of stuff
there so I'm saying to myself drawing
some conclusions I'm say mrs. King how
are you making it her dignified manner
mrs. King always always paused even when
she was on the phone mrs. King paused
and said Bernard you know if it wasn't
for the Jewish community I wouldn't be
here I paused that was not what I
expected so if you carried it on because
she can see the look of my face was a
startled look so she said let me tell
you something more if it wasn't for the
Jewish community there would have been
no civil rights movement pause pause
so tonight I say to the Jewish community
that's here thank you thank you a
community that doesn't need recognition
a community that doesn't even tell mrs.
King where the checks come from all she
knows that she can count on it and
friends let me tell you you might have
wondered how Jesse Jackson made his
living you might have wondered how
Abernathy Reverend Abernathy made his
living the Jewish community and you
think about all the buses you think
about all the coordination you think
about all that needed to be done to give
people where they needed to be we owe a
debt of gratitude to the Jewish
community for what they've done and I
salute and say thank you this evening to
the Jewish community that's here tonight
for our community owes you a debt of
gratitude for standing with us at a time
when we needed it now understand the
conversation then went mrs. King you got
to help me understand because when i
looked at my black-and-white TV i
thought i saw white people there and so
I'm saying were there no Baptist there
where they know Methodist there were
there no clergy from the Lutheran Church
mrs. King smiled and said Bernard the
southern white churches did not do a
thing to help us in fact you need to
understand the churches supported the
Klan the churches did everything they
could to keep us from doing what we
needed to do she said every now and then
there might have been a sprinkle from
the north of Catholics young who would
come and sit at the counters and so
friends my message tonight is that the
fight is not over we need some some
Caucasians to step into Montgomery and
let me just bring it closer we do some
Caucasians to step into Pittsburgh
you know I I've appreciated the term a
lie I appreciate the term support i
appreciate the term I'm in your corner
before is you're not walking with me
unless you walking with me holding my
arm you know I don't want your check
I've said two churches around the
country don't send another check if
you're not going to take that check
personally Methodist Church lutheran
church catholic church and for so many
of them they've left our community
anyway I want you to come back so for me
I'm saying clearly I'm saying clearly
this is all of our ward this is all of
our fight and we all have to step into
it Pittsburgh come alive so that was
there was very an awakening for me to
understand that the church was not there
you see I grew up pentecostal and my
Pentecostal roots has some connection
because there was a white Pentecostal on
a black chemicals to me and all of it
when you stop and think about it you get
so tired of saying black church and
white church when there's one God over
all so at some point Pittsburgh we got
to come together we got to make it work
so I got more and more information from
mrs King about this man because I wanted
to understand how in the midst of that
you're looking at pastors that are that
maybe or your friends or pastors that
you have meetings with but they're on
the other side how does that man do this
how does he walk that walk well to put
some of this in context because I
realized not every one is from America
in this room tonight I want to just go
through a little bit of the story a
little bit of who dr. King was and I'll
interjected some different points some
things that I was tall personally from
here that you may not get in a book but
let me just begin by saying dr. King was
born in Atlanta Georgia 19
29 as a child he never failed to ask
discerning questions about the world
around him mrs. King said he was always
asking questions to his mother and his
father though his father was a Reverend
King initially had many doubts about the
Christian religion as it was only after
years of schooling that he became
convinced that religion could be both
intellectually and emotionally
satisfying King learned to read before
he entered great school he attended oval
fork elementary school which was a
private school associated with Atlanta
University his parents paid $25 a year
which covered all of his expenses miss
lemon one of his favorite teachers
taught him how to be independent she
taught him if there was an injustice
that he could rebel but still keep his
dignity and find quiet ways to resist
she inspired her students to learn about
black history and take pride in their
heritage she took the class on Phil's
field trips to visit the successful
black businessmen and professionals her
students started each day by singing the
song lift every voice and see mrs. King
said he talked about mrs. lemon quite a
bit he went on to 10 booker t washington
high school in atlanta he was younger
than most of the students and also
skipped some subjects because he already
knew the subject matter on one occasion
he and his teacher of riding on a bus
when the bus filled up with people the
driver asked him to stand up and let two
white people have their seats it was the
law but Martin saw this is injustice and
he never forgot the incident when he was
15 he entered Morehouse College after
two years he decided he could best serve
others by becoming a minister at age 17
he became assistant men
of Ebenezer Baptist Church where his
father was minister the following year
he graduated from college from morehouse
college he was aged 19 king was born
Martin no Michael Luther King jr. and I
say that and I say that slowly because I
want you to understand that when the boy
was six years old two white playmates
were told not to play with him and his
mother had to explain about segregation
that it was a social condition and he
was just as good as anyone else but the
father his father lifted his vision even
higher he told him about a German
reformed theologian by the name of
Martin Luther the great leader of the
Reformation and he said from now on we
both will be named after him that's
where Martin Luther King came from in
1948 Martin Luther King jr. took his
sociology degree from Morehouse College
and attended Crozer Theological Seminary
in Chester Pennsylvania there he thrives
in all his studies becoming
valedictorian of his class in 1951 an
elected student body president he earned
a fellowship for graduate study but
martin also and this is just information
i want you to have because i want you to
understand i think so many times we've
put him on a pedestal and we've said he
wasn't human he wasn't part of us but
this man was he had his challenges he
had his issues he had his struggles with
life like we all have had but he
rebelled in graduate school against his
father's more conservative influenced by
drinking beer and playing pool while at
college
now to us that does not sound like
but understand in 1950 drinking beer as
a minister plan pool was not considered
cool he became involved with a white
woman and went through a difficult time
before he could break off the
relationship but he did during his last
year in seminary Martin came under the
influence of theologian Reinhold Niebuhr
a classmate of his father's at Morehouse
College niebuhr became a mentor to
Martin challenging his views of theology
neighbor was probably the single most
important influence other than Mahatma
Gandhi on Martin's intellectual and
spiritual development after being
accepted at several colleges for his
doctoral study including Yale and
Edinburgh in Scotland King enrolled in
Boston University during the work on his
doctorate King met Coretta Scott an
aspiring singer and musician at the New
England Conservatory school in Boston
they were married in June 1953 and had
four children then you know the rest you
know much of the rest on March second
1955 at a 15 year old girl refused to
give up her seat to a white man in
Montgomery Claudette Colvin was arrested
and taken to jail the rest became
history on the evening of 42 year old
rosa parks board at the cleveland avenue
bus to go home from an exhausting day at
work she said at the front row of the
colored section in the middle of the bus
as the bus travel then route all the
seats in the white section filled up
then several more white passengers
the bus the bus driver noted there were
several white men standing and demanded
that parks and several other
african-americans give up their seats
for the white men three other African
American passengers reluctantly gave up
their places but parks tired from her
day refused to get up the driver asked
her again to give up her seat and again
she refused she was arrested booked for
violating the montgomery city code and
her trial a week later a 30-minute
hearing so when dr. King heard all of
this he pondered it he thought hard mrs.
King said but he came to a conclusion he
said we have no alternative but to
protest for many years we have shown an
amazing patience but we have come here
tonight to be saved from patients that
makes us patient with anything less than
freedom and justice when he arrived in
Montgomery let me say it again when King
walked into Montgomery he saw a city
that was highly segregated one of the
Jim Crow laws required the first four
rolls on public buses to be served
reserved for white people while colored
riders have a sit in the back of the bus
yet barely after he arrived this
incident happened with Miss Rosa Parks
the Montgomery Improvement Association
was formed with the n-double-a-cp
executive committee and officers of the
Montgomery n-double-a-cp which at that
point mint in the state the boycott
lasted for over a year during which time
King was threatened mrs. King said
arrested and even had their house bombed
however by December 1956 the m.i.a had
won a clear victory the United States
District Court ruled in broader versus
Gail that racial segregation on buses
was unconstitutional it wasn't just that
doc
King became the leader of the civil
rights movement that made him so
extraordinary that's what I want to
capture for us tonight it was the way in
which he did it King advocated civil
disobedience the nonviolent resistance
against unjust laws non-violence he said
is a powerful and just weapon which cuts
without wounding in Nobles the man who
yields it civil rights activists
organized demonstrations marches boycott
strikes and voter registrations and
drives the peaceful forms of protests
were often met with all kinds of vicious
threats vicious rumors beatings and
worst mckean continue to emphasize how
important it was that the civil rights
movement not sink to the level of the
racist behavior and the hate mongers
they were fighting against them we must
forever conduct our struggle on the high
plane of dignity and discipline King's
philosophy of tough mindedness and
tender-hearted pneus was not only highly
effective but it gave the civil rights
movement in inspiring moral authority
and grace we're friends the rest is
history you all know about the march on
Washington if any of you have watched
CNN or any of the shows today they
probably play the piece of that well it
says as it has been stated already our
world is in crisis we're suffering from
a dearth of leadership and probably some
of that same dearth happens here in
Pittsburgh but friends I'm on a
university campus with those new
leadership budding here I'm in a
community that I know needs leadership
the greater pittsburgh area but also the
campus that I'm speaking to leaders are
blond from side to side by the powerful
winds of political correctness society
whims and self greed
truth is ignored in life and death
decisions are postponed arrogance has
replaced discernment and small
mindedness has overtaken vision and
principal all this is seen as the status
quo is maintained we cannot continue to
maintain the status quo trans as long as
we sit in this room and go back to our
homes and continue listening to music
and reading books and doing this the
same things day in and day out the one
percent will continue to rule our lives
dr. King would speak out against the one
percent dr. King would speak out against
a whole list of things this wave of a
lack of leadership has engulfed
Pittsburgh is engulfed our country has
engulfed Washington and is wreaking
havoc on our country this truth is not
just saddening it is in fact dangerous
for the whole world that is in the midst
of such great upheaval the true
leadership must learn to look around at
the world at its events and discerning
eyes we must then make true choices
regarding the future and direction of
our people I spoke a couple weekends ago
to my fraternity and after spending some
weeks researching what I was going to
say I begin to have a conversation with
them about how men treat women and doing
my research I discovered that the number
one health issue for women in America
and around the world is violence against
women / perpetrated by men dr. King
would have a conversation about that men
dr. King would have a clear conversation
about that and so I speak to this
community here if this community of men
I want you to work with women to take
back tonight I want you to work with
women here to make sure a no woman is
treated without the dignity and the
respect she deserves and I've said this
around the country more women improbable
here women here probably have the
highest grade point average as a group
over men I know that this your tuition I
mean your your enrollment numbers
they're more men here than women but our
young men need to understand at some
point their first second or third job
they may have a female supervisor so as
we're objectifying women in the
classroom and objectifying women in
porno and objectifying women around our
lives that same woman may someday be the
woman you stare in the face and ask for
a raise so friends part of our work and
part of our work at university settings
is not just a set of set aside time and
space for Women's Center but the set
aside time and space for a men's center
the numbers are despicable the numbers
of African American men who graduate
from colleges and universities in
America and i'm not sure what your
graduation rates are here but i say to
you we need to figure out how we care
for me and just as much as we care for
women i believe dr. king will make this
an important issue i believe dr. king
also would make an issue that we must
figure out how we share the wealth how
we share the significance how we share
what we have with others you see I don't
believe the universe gave me gifts gave
me abilities for me to hoard to myself
so I slated this intellectual group of
people here i say to you i challenge you
to figure out how you give back because
somebody gave up their life for you to
be here I don't care what your ancestry
whether it's german italian irish are
africa you stand on the backs the
shoulders of somebody who blame
and I've for you to be here and as power
obligation in our right to give back to
make sure that a whole other generation
has the same opportunity
America needs new leadership and so I
say to this population here I came close
to fulfilling my dream mrs. King called
me shortly after I got back to Kansas
City from that first trip and mrs. King
said President Carter is looking to
appoint a commission of young people and
she said I gave him Thurgood Marshall's
daughter's name I gave him Andrew
Young's daughter's name and also gave
him a young man's name from Kansas I
gave him yours and so I was a part of
this presidential commission to advise
the White House on issues that affect
the poor and the disadvantaged my area
of responsibility since I was serving on
the Kansas Board of Regents was higher
education and I knew that America needed
to figure out how it could find more
poor and middle-class students so they
could go to college so we were able to
influence the Carter White House to
create legislation to expand the SEO ji
and to expand the Pell Grant so that
more students could go to college so if
any of you are using the Pell Grant
about my commission that opportunity led
me to go around the country and if any
of you know how political candidates are
designed are made as they put you out
there to see how well you do in crowds
they give you a speech and they send you
around the country one weekend I gave 10
speeches around the country but I was 28
by then and I had the Democratic Party
beginning to speak to me about being
governor of Kansas about sit being
senator from Kansas but I was 28 years
old I had just gotten married the best
of my life was just ahead of me my world
in many ways was out of control so I
said mrs. King I need to step back if I
were 38 or if I were 48 I'd stay on this
trajectory but at 28 I just can't do it
so friends I stepped back
so that I could be here tonight to say
to you that there's opportunities ahead
of you there are things you can do that
by taking advantage of every opportunity
people who come close to you people who
are next to you that opportunity that
moment in time when my family was
connected to mrs. King and I want you to
understand I traveled with her I was her
personal assistant when you look if you
look at the video of her funeral the
King children were sitting on the second
or third row and my family was sitting
behind them I rode from the King family
home to the church new birth Christian
we rode with that we have continued our
relationship so what that taught me was
there are no accidents in life you're
going to meet people you're going to sit
beside someone in an airplane you're
going to come in contact with someone in
the bookstore your paths are going to
cross people who have significant
influence on your life and some of you
are going to walk by them because they
don't look like you some of you are
going to ignore them because they smell
different or they look different or they
come off different but i say to you
friends that may be your ticket to walk
in the Pittsburgh that may be your
ticket to walk into a whole nother space
a whole other place in time because the
universe the universe the universe does
not have accidents it's always creating
opportunities for us to get to our dream
to get to our destiny to get to where
we're supposed to be so I say to you
tonight to take advantage of everything
that you're doing here to learn to grow
but to walk outside your comfort zones
walk into places where you are
uncomfortable and I even say to my
african-american friends if you have
such an organization as the Black
Student Union that's not the only
organization you're a part of you figure
out ways that you socialize get to know
people who don't look like you so that
when you end up in corporate
you know how white man thinks so when
you get to corporate America you know
how an Indian or Chinese or Japanese
woman things and you can mingle and you
can move and you can act like you know
where you are and have the confidence to
do so on so many campuses that I go the
blacks are here whites are here the
Asians are here and I'm saying it's time
out for that kind of living sign out for
that kind of learning if we're going to
progress to be a global community we got
to figure out how we have collective
dialogue work together places to go
together and we move together let me
close with one of my favorite quotes
from dr. King the ultimate measure of a
man and I add a woman is not where he
stands in moments of comfort and
convenience but where he or she stands
at times of challenge and controversy
the true neighbor will risk his position
his prestige and even his life for the
welfare of others in dangerous valleys
and hazardous pathways he will lift some
bruised some beaten some broken person
to a higher and more noble life carnegie
mellon university pittsburgh community
that's our mission to lift some bruised
and broken person to a higher and more
noble life it's my pleasure to be here
this evening
you